[Musica]
[Applauso]
ciao
quando quando ti chiamano lodovico con
nome intero vuol dire che ti trattano
come un adulto oppure è la mamma ti che
ti stai gridando
lodovico non farla quella cosa buona
sera buongiorno
non sono preparato
io sono preparato
è una sensazione cosa c'è
adesso sì sì adesso sto qua ma poi
faccio anche i miei giri non ti
preoccupare lui e jumbo è l'incarnazione
di mia madre quando mia madre non c'è
fategli un applauso
ha un cuore calabrese come ogni madre
vero
mi raccomando cerca di stare ecco
e non sapere le cose è una delle
sensazioni più belle della vita
arrivare in un posto e non sapere cosa
succederà è una delle cose più belle
della vita ma adesso proviamo a giocarci
questi diciotto minuti che si
riveleranno per me ovviamente troppi
pochi e
con alcune regole del gioco allora
secondo me
voi dovete aiutarmi in questa maniera
qua
qualsiasi cosa che io dica che voi non
capite
mimì urlate contro che non si capisce
i telefoni cosa importa delle suonerie
dei telefoni dovrebbero essere
rigorosamente accese se qualcuno vi
chiama
rispondo io
qualsiasi intervento domanda posta del
cuore va tutto va tutto bene in
qualsiasi momento non c'è nessuna regola
18 anni
entro entro in accademia faccia il
provino faccio il primo giorno di
lezione di accademia 10 il direttore
dell'accademia
che è un personaggio
strano e fantasmagorico e che ha una
dizione molto particolare per essere un
accademia d arte drammatica operatori
tuttora se telefoni stati parlando con
la scritta via telefonica della
accademia nico pepe
insomma noi ci dice ricordatevi questo
momento prima frase ricordatevi questo
momento perché in questo momento voi non
sapete cosa succederà
frase molto bella dopo ci ha fatto fare
una serie di esercizi di quelli che
fanno anche
anche nei corsi per motivare gli
imprenditori che tipo ti butti di
schiena da dei tavoli con la gente che
ti prende all'ultimo ma hanno preso sono
ancora qui e fortunatamente non sono
diventato imprenditore e
e
è però è vero cioè io potrei essere un
discreto parco giochi della stessa
perché sono uno completamente incapace
di vivere
mi sento a disagio
in qualsiasi situazione anche con
persone che amo che conosco da tanto
tempo e invece non mi vergogno di stare
su un palco mai è l'unico posto in cui
mi sento a mio agio in non me ne importa
un cazzo di sapere cosa fare perché è
casa mia dice lorenzo lavia che è un
attore molto bravo è un regista molto
bravo è figlio di un altro attore molto
bravo e regista molto bravo che si
chiama gabriele lavia dice una cosa
sottile magnifica come sono le parole
sanno essere dice il piacere di stare in
scena non di essere in scena non il
piacere di farsi vedere piacere di
giocare qua
di stare qua e quindi io mi presento che
non so niente
come vuole la teoria sulla biomeccanica
di mai alcol e poi perché mi piace
rischiare e poi perché lo spezzino è una
zona in cui in cui ci sono molti matti
voi venite da un passo io io sono
emiliano io ve lo devo dire questa cosa
del della mortadella dentro la cozza
cioè no ma io io me lo chiedo con
stupore sincero non giudico ma dico io
mi immagino proprio questo maiale che si
affaccia al tramonto di fronte al mare
come in un quadro romantico
dell'ottocento tedesco e dice io io
voglio entrare lì
ma sei un maiale io ce la farò
tu ce la farai e pistorius sarà l'uomo
più veloce del mondo
e
io in effetti a spezia ho rischiato la
vita
credo che abbia senso raccontare questa
cosa sto guardando il tempo perché ho
paura che scorre troppo velocemente
prova a raccontare questo aneddoto con
gli strumenti che ho al di sotto dei 35
minuti non so se ci riesco
in quel caso comunque fatevi chiamare da
qualcuno che poi mi dice di andare
affanculo e
allora e io a spezia vengo la prima
volta
nel 2012
2012 e il primo tour di un disco che
all'improvviso ci ha fatto diventare una
band di successo nella scena
indipendente che una cosa che non esiste
più perché non c'è più la scena
indipendente c'è solo uno scaffale nella
libreria di spotify e
e vengo qui
dopo aver provato cosa che non facevamo
mai perché io odio anche provare oltre a
odiare prepararmi e e abbiamo provato in
un locale a bologna sul ponte di via
stalingrado
che l'unico posto dove mi capita di
andare a suonare
da solo
per inventarmi qualcosa
e
e arrivo alla spezia e suoniamo in un
posto dell'università
non chiedetemi dove io non ho la patente
arrivo scaricato dal furgone ci sono ci
sono 80 persone in tutto a me sembrano
tantissime e
ci sono c'è una ragazza molto bella
molto bella
in generale ha spesso ci sono delle
ragazze molto belle
c'è forse questa cosa della mortadella
nelle cozze
e reyer vabbè comunque
questa ragazza molto bella ed
erano delle persone che per la prima
volta la prima volta che vedo delle
persone che hanno un biglietto di un mio
concerto e questa cosa fa un certo
effetto ve lo garantisco la cosa che
pensi quando c'è qualcuno che paga per
sentirti cantare tra l'altro stonato
come sono io è
questa cosa non ha senso
e dire questa cosa non ha senso è una
delle cose più belle della vita e
mi ricordo l'emozione e il senso di
onnipotenza che mi dava il fatto che ci
fossero 80 100 120 persone che pagavano
per venire a sentire me era una vendetta
della vita era una vendetta di tutta la
sfiga che io sono e rimango era
era un senso di onnipotenza che non
avrai mai più dopo
primo perché quando le dimensioni
crescono tu fai più fatica ad avere
contatto con le persone poi perché le
persone credono di non poter entrare in
contatto con te e poi perché perché la
prima botta è tutta un'altra cosa e
quindi io pensavo di poter fare un sacco
all'amore con un sacco di donne
ed è stato l'unico momento della mia
vita in cui ho creduto a questa cosa
così all'improvviso
amici portate qui dove mettono la
mortadella nelle cozze che
nascerà qualcosa e
quindi vedo questa ragazza
edicola frase più da sfigato della
storia della mia vita adesso ve lo dirò
ma è così da sfigato perché l'ho anche
detto a con pudore
non sono stato neanche uno sfigato fino
in fondo che albi che sono con me
chi è quella la e
io io io gli rispondo
quella che dorme con me stanotte
che schifo amici che cosa vorrei
almeno l'avessi detta volgare avrebbe
avuto leader la dignità di una porcata e
invece no d'or comunque dorme
si sa mai
finisce il concerto io vado da lei
cominciamo a parlare lei è una 23enne
carica d'entusiasmo con gli occhi grandi
come il sole che è convinta di essere
nel parco giochi della vita perché ha 23
anni ogni tanto lo pensi e che va al
triplo della velocità rispetto a me che
mi dice sì prendiamo andiamo portami
portami portami al mare va bene andiamo
al mare certo io ero pronto a
scodinzolare ovunque in quel momento e
poi mi dice
prendi prendi la macchina andiamo e io
dico non ho la patente
la prendi il furgone non ha la patente o
uguale per il furto però è che posso
portare via il friuli adesso vado via
con te va bene va bene fa niente fa
niente allora allora andiamo giù al
porto di spezia andiamo andiamo giù al
porto di spezia va bene va bene e noi
attraversiamo il centro di spezie leidi
ci aspetta io adesso salgo su dei miei
che tanto stanno dormendo prendiamo due
bottiglie di vino rosso
ok vediamo questi due bottiglie di vino
rosso arriviamo al porto di spezia ci
sediamo sul porto che non
non è il posto più romantico del mondo
il porto di spesa giusta si può dire
no non è lì dove i maiali si sono
affacciati pensando io voglio diventare
una cosa
è
e niente e beviamo una bottiglia di vino
rosso a testa
e anche a quella temperatura etilica
salute guarda in effetti è un racconto
che lo merita
a quella temperatura etilica succede che
lei mi dice ho un'idea
ascoltiamo
potremmo salire su dei miei io prendo di
nascosto le chiavi della macchina di mio
padre io non ho la patente però una
volta ho provato a guidare mi è riuscito
e io ti porto alla mia casa al mare che
a porto venere che di là e mi indica una
strada sopra dei tornanti
se in quelle cose tipo quando quando
esci da gotham city nel cartone ri
marcia e io penso e io penso è davvero
un'idea del cazzo
e le dico facciamolo
questa è una delle poche cose che ho
capito nella vita se sei nel dubbio di
stare facendo una cazzata pensaci bene
ma se sei sicuro di fare una cazzata
falla
palla lo dico sul serio
prendiamo questa macchina e
deve uscire dal parcheggio ma
questo è il padre
che finalmente sa tutto
[Risate]
si preoccupi signora r
devo uscire dalla macchina non sa uscire
dal parcheggio non sa uscire dal
parcheggio
sbatte contro la macchina di fronte
parte l'allarme sbatte contro macchina
dietro parte un altro allarme
cominci cioè cominciamo a sentire le
sirene della polizia all'improvviso è
oltre siamo dentro un film di john
carpenter lei esce e non si sa come
infila quei tornanti e guida per dieci
minuti che sono stati credo 153 anni
percepiti in questa totalmente ubriaca
costantemente nella corsia opposta
rallentando in tutti i rettilinee
accelerando in tutte le curve
io ho un certo punto
cominciò a gridare a fare qualsiasi cosa
cercare di scendere in corsa di liz
mente sono totalmente sobrio ovviamente
la paura della morte mi ha fatto saggio
e
fino a un certo punto e poi dopo i primi
23 minuti penso vabbè allora è chiaro
che io adesso muoio ci può anche stare
una morte abbastanza rock and roll va
bene e comunque la vendetta rispetto
allo sfigato dei 15 anni però speriamo
di morire perché se io qua rimango tipo
bloccato nel corpo tutta la vita
arrivano un brutto ma rimango scemo più
più più di così
che ci crediate o no fatto un lavoro di
fantasia se non ce la fate e speriamo di
morire è invece in qualche maniera
arriviamo a portovenere
lei parcheggia la macchina e scendiamo
in questa spiaggetta di questo posto
meraviglioso lei si spoglia
credo credo che avesse imparato a
spogliarsi da arturo brachetti cioè fao
lo so muove una mano all'improvviso e
nulla e io e io no e io non capivo
niente
e io mi butto in acqua e lei starà
pensando questo rincoglionito a un certo
punto faremo l'amore con questo io
invece sento l'acqua gelata e penso che
sono vivo e non mi importa di niente
cominciò a nuotare disperatamente
nuotano con lei che a un certo punto
infreddolita poverina si siede e si
siede lì ad aspettarmi e torniamo
indietro e va tutto bene mi bacia lei
perché figurati signora il coraggio di
baciarla
amy e mi porta in macchina e mettiamo
mettiamo un pacchetto di paglia di qua e
le mie mutande bagnate di là e siamo
pronti per tornare a casa in quella casa
che a 900 metri sul rettilineo
ed è tutto facile lei è già uscita dal
parcheggio e dobbiamo andare ai 10
allora perché chi se ne importa siamo
vivi non facciamo più cazzate e io le
dico o alla fine incredibile ma è andato
tutto
in quel momento
lei
entra completamente con la sua macchina
dentro un'auto parcheggiata
come un maiale dentro una cozza
e fonde il semiasse della dell'auto
e a quel punto mi dice ho un'idea
adesso noi facciamo così andiamo a casa
non amiamo un'ora poi domattina
prendiamo la prima corriera che i miei
ancora dormono io torno a casa
metto le chiavi della macchina dentro la
giacca di mio padre e poi simuliamo un
furto io penso è un'idea del cazzo
facciamola
e e arriviamo là in qualche maniera poi
dobbiamo tornare indietro perché ci
accorgiamo che nella macchina avevamo
lasciato un pacchetto di paglia e delle
mutande bagnate che poco poco
funzionavano con la versione del furto e
e torniamo indietro e poi torniamo e poi
torniamo ora a consegnare queste chiavi
lei mi offre una colazione con gli
occhiali da sole in un bar vicino al
porto di spezia torniamo a dormire non
faccio a tempo ad addormentarmi che
vengono prendermi per portarmi in
un'altra città perché quell estate
abbiamo fatto 90 date in tre mesi
e non eravamo mai a casa e non capivamo
niente e forse forse eravamo felici e
lei vi manda un messaggio sul mio nokia
33 10 che ostinatamente conservato fino
al 2014
con scritto che suo padre ovviamente ne
aveva sgamata
e che si era incazzato morte che l'aveva
mandata in terapia da questa bravissima
si chiama stefania andreoli
io
mi sento la sua cozza
e
e non capivamo niente
e facevamo solo dei danni
ma la verità è che l'unica cosa che ci
rendeva luminosi e speciali era che non
capivamo niente facevamo solo dei danni
perché la perfezione è una gran rottura
di [ __ ]
e l'unica cosa che ha senso su un palco
è spogliarsi
e nudi
siamo più brutti
è questo che ci fa così belli e
e tutto questo per dire che quel locale
dove ci preparavamo per cultura
improbabile
io ci ho suonato un po di volte e adesso
questo punto per me un luogo di festa
quel ponte lì è un luogo divertente ce
n'era anche un altro locale di fronte un
altro posto c'è anche un improbabile
club per scambisti che non ho mai avuto
il coraggio di rientrare ma sono curioso
di cosa succede in centro a bologna in
un club per scambisti
chissà chissà 50 anni di partito
comunista come si rapporta loro
e non riesco a pensare ad altro che al
fatto che una settimana fa un ragazzo
non ha accettato di essere un disastro
come siamo anche noi ha invitato i suoi
genitori per la sua laurea ma la sua
laurea non esisteva e si è buttato da
quel ponte
e
mancano 19 18 17 e io in quel locale ho
suonato con una band che aveva scritto
un pezzo su un altro ragazzo che faceva
l'università e si è buttato dal settimo
piano
e diceva queste cose qua e sono gli
ultimi tre secondi
norman amico mio
siamo così piccoli che quando cadiamo
non ci sente nessuno 1 noi non lo
facciamo
il boato che fa l'impresario il boato
che fa il capo di stato grazie
[Applauso]